so i watched that and then i watched uh
i finished the night stalker documentary
have you seen that yet that's the
richard ramirez yes
yo i watched when we watched the last
episode and
you got oh yeah because i had one
episode i was like what the [ __ ] is this
i i knew like what was uh like everybody
knows that
i've known of him but i never knew the
exact same i know he's a serial killer
but dude
talk about a dart he has to be the worst
serial killer of all time
really him or that btk killer he they're
[ __ ] up there
which one was the btk uh buying torture
kill
he was i think he was more on these
because he always goes he wasn't out
here richard ramirez
bad [ __ ] right he had women when i
saw what he had women showing up to the
women like we're good looking dude once
he got his teeth fixed
before the teeth though oh he looks he
looks like a straight demon but yeah he
looks
so demonic but his back
his background's crazy because jay said
him and
that yeah that one i mean is that you
might say i'm demonized
yeah he's crazy man he believes satan
was like he was doing the work of satan
yeah
[ __ ] like just his eyes wait who fixed
his teeth he unfixed
in jail uh i think afterwards he did
oh wow like he got yeah he's like a good
looking he's not a bad looking dude yeah
serial killer not bad looking good but
uh
jay and his wife are talking about uh
his wife anthony goes do you think he
was
born evil or is it your upbringing and i
think it's your upbringing
oh is that is that sure because his
upbringing was [ __ ] full
what was it so he was like one of five
his dad
was a cop in mexico then when they came
over the states he did something
different
but his dad through discipline would
make up like uh
time to like a cross and leave him in
the cemetery oh yeah come on how long
for a long long like overnight yeah and
then and then uh his uncle was in
vietnam
and was uh would show him pictures of
all the women he murdered and raped
in vietnam so at a young age he was like
five so that was his environment that
was the environment so it became okay
like
he associated sexual like pleasure with
violence so that's how he came about so
he oh okay so that was his thing he was
he would have sex with him and then kill
him and then
and then i also looked in this so the i
get ball deep and serious yeah
so uh that the night stalker documentary
it's a good job but the narratives on
the cops which is kind of stupid
like the cops are the they gave them
they put too much emphasis on the cop
they didn't catch them for like a year
dude i know a year but that neighborhood
was about to [ __ ] them up the
neighborhood
that's the ending but uh that that
documentary they they said his first
kills that here in l.a
like some old lady or something like
that but his first killing was actually
in uh
san francisco of like a seven-year-old
eight-year-old
and oh yeah because he dude because at
the end that cop was talking about how
he was walking him to somewhere in his
cell or something and he was like
that's you know that's even different
murders yeah oh that's like
i think he got accused or he got uh
charged
uh with guilty for thirteen murders but
they say it's like twenty five dollars
he's doing this he's his first one was
when he was like 17
[ __ ] or some little girl and [ __ ]
no workout and then so that uh i saw
there was a part about a six-year-old
girl that testified
or something like that yep she got away
and then one he let go
one got away that was his thing like he
would rape like
women kids boys in their apartment
just crazy back then in l.a they leave
their door wide open
which is well like you couldn't get
around with it today
because now like everyone's kind of
savvy to it but back then like
there's no central air conditioning so
when i was like really hot looks like he
flourished during the summer
because everyone left their [ __ ] open
windows doors everyone left windows open
because they want that that air
remember you shot that girl in the face
and the bullet ricocheted off her keys
and he was about to and she ran around
the back i don't know why because she
was
her roommate was already dead so she was
like
she's already dead so she ran she could
have got away but she ran back
behind the door thinking like oh he's
not coming back here and he
they kind of like bumped into each other
and she was like come on you already
shot me you already shot me once don't
do it again
he was are you right and just left her
and just wanted an evil dude man
just a bad bad dude man yeah
yeah i don't think he was born that way
that was his brain
and they said his victims too like he
was like he didn't want to surprise
anybody he wanted to make sure they saw
him because he got pleasure seeing their
suffering just a bad
individual man god damn was he going out
with after specific people or is just
anybody that was the problem anybody
oh okay that's usually they try it's
hard to get trends yeah because
because jeffrey dahmer he was eating
women
no i thought he was gonna have to do gay
men oh eating good dudes yeah he was
going
women too but gay men yeah oh got it
okay he was do women too
yeah but mainly gay men learn back
damn dark [ __ ] i just think yeah i just
think and then
that cecil hotel uh in uh right off skid
row
down here yeah probably where chin used
to live
it is a hotel where uh
rodriguez stayed ramirez
yeah ramirez really damn that hotel is
just freaking not good then
yeah he's so he stayed at that cesar
hotel forever and because they never
questioned like they said he would like
murder stone have blood all over him
yeah you just take his clothes off dumb
in the trash and walk into the lobby so
but naked and no one would say anything
okay so they knew he didn't have fun why
was that trial so long
four years yeah why was it so long most
expensive trial since
o.j simpson but like because they knew
he he did all the stuff what was
like you know appeals and [ __ ] oh okay
crazy man oh and then well here's the
other problem no it was for the death
penalty
the the death penalty but then also the
jury
they they couldn't find a jury that
wasn't biased
so they went through like thousands
thousands of jurors to try to find
people that weren't biased or weren't
familiar with his case
because you can't bring in people like
they can't bring in an all-black jury
for o.j simpson
yeah we can't have it yeah you can't do
it
you know what i'm saying yeah yeah so
for him they were trying to find the
certain jurors that didn't know weren't
familiar with the case
and then also what delayed is when the
jurors was murdered halfway through
the thing they thought it was tied to
the night stalker but it was it was just
it was a domestic dispute and the
husband or boyfriend killed her then
killed himself
but that like so there's like all these
weird things that like drew it out
gosh when he drew that pentagram on his
hand and showed it to the [ __ ] nuts
right
right it's like bro how about this how
about uh
sean penn went to uh jail when he was
filming something
and he was in the same like holding area
but
uh uh [ __ ] ramirez was down
like the way and um sean penn was
i think or maybe was the night stalker
wanted something from champagne because
they found out he was in prison
sean penn was like the nightstalkers
here like yeah he wants a signed note
from you
and uh sean penn was like tell him to
send me something first so you know the
guards like here
and so he sent him uh because he was in
there for like punching somebody on set
you know something stupid
oh champagne champagne was punched
somebody on set so he goes
uh keep hitting him uh you know whatever
night stalker six six six six and sean
penn replied back was like i hope you
burn in [ __ ] hell
like went hard in the paint on him he's
like i hope you never get out of here
and i hope you die in here yeah and then
he did
he died yeah but he was only on in
prison for uh 15 years
and died of cancer but they said when he
died he had some weird blood condition
he made his eyes turn neon green
how scary maybe he was a demon how scary
is that
they said that yeah they said like the
security guards like what the [ __ ]
kind of cancer you got yeah it made his
eyes turn neon green
weird huh hell bro you go hard on this
stuff i get into it listen to podcasting
and everything
it's time for me to listen to man it's
not it's not tough for me to listen to
because they're dead
if they were on the loose i probably
wouldn't be listening oh yeah
yeah but like that makes sense he's not
gonna do [ __ ] to me now yeah
charles manslaughter [ __ ] to me now
they're both dead yeah but that cecil
hotel's [ __ ] weird and so crap
what's up with this hotel keep this
hotel out so
ramirez uh there and then another serial
killer stayed there for a long time
there was a serial killer from uh
austria
and so he was killing women and
strangling with their brawls
and then uh left and came over to the
states
to like do ride-alongs with the cops
because because at the time it was like
really bad like skid row
so he was like i'm doing research so
then they figured out that women started
to die because they can strangle by
brawls
so the austrian cops contacted the la
cops like hold up
are these women dying from brawls they
get like this the same guy over here so
they figure out he's the only one this
reporter
yeah that was the one doing it so they
sent him
they put him back to us austria put him
on trial
and he was like a model assistant in
prison they let this dude out in like
three years because like he's recovered
he's good
he's reformed they let him out of course
dude starts killing again
ah so now he's in prison for life out
there
and then also the season hotel and
there's a documentary on netflix coming
out in the ceso hotel
did they tear it down [ __ ] no that [ __ ]
still up
yeah yeah i stayed there that's crazy
you stayed there by myself dude
why i didn't want to drive it was my
birthday when
this is a long time ago this is uh maybe
a little bit before the girl
and did you did you know about some of
those no but i remember feeling creeped
out when i was there and i was by myself
too which i'm never by myself but i
don't want to drive drunk so i was like
all right let me just check it out
where are you thinking i don't i didn't
i didn't recently i was like it was so
cheap yeah it was so cheap yeah
but they've had like a bunch of suicides
there a bunch of murders two serial
killers stayed there
and then this young lady who is from
canada
she's the one that went missing they
found in the water tower
have you heard this girl she's so creepy
dude you don't know this story yeah
so she uh there's video of her in the
sea hotel
and she's like staring at the hotel like
the
the elevator and she's like terrified
and she goes missing
you know how they found her they found
her because uh the people
in the hotel were complaining of the
water being like shitty
like coming out all weird looking and
tasting different
because she was in the water tower they
found her dead in the water tower
here's what's interesting about the
water tower that water tower tower
it took like cops and [ __ ]
construction workers to pry this thing
open they're like there's no way a human
could get up here and
jump into there there's no way so they
can't figure out how she got in there
now you know she was under a ton of
medication
for bipolar manic depressive and all
this [ __ ]
so well look at this the elevator won't
close it's
like it's super creepy how scared she is
she's like hiding from something
see that it is so creepy
shout out to the cecil hotel uh
what the [ __ ] yeah i do netflix doing it
it's coming out soon
a dock on it if you go back to him
there's oh my gosh there's a trailer for
it
oh the one movie i gotta watch still
nightcrawler
yeah that's a good one jake gyllenhaal
yeah that was great it was good yeah
there it is
what are this right here you probably
can't use this but i'll play for you no
turn it up jen picture the cecil hotel
that's where the case starts to go
excuse your hand movements are very
strange in your routing
could happen yeah how long have i maybe
been the manager i'm hooked up
i know i would leave immediately i'd go
find a new job yeah she's just standing
there like it's [ __ ] yeah this place
is crazy
and she looks like there's a [ __ ]
together yeah she goes somewhere else
you can work anywhere anywhere and
that's where you want to work
yeah how much she getting paid i'm gonna
tell you it's i don't know if it's
haunted or what there's been a ton of
bad [ __ ] that's happened there but it's
also in like the seediest
area of la it's skid row dude yeah it's
cheap hotel
so yeah how much you guys are hanging
there like stay there do you remember
maybe like 30 or something 30 dollars
a skit wrote that smell [ __ ] it's like
the underworld of
you know it's in the underworld it's the
hotel of the underworld so of course you
have bad [ __ ] there i don't know if it's
haunted
there's been a uh the only picture they
have where they think it's haunted and
who knows this picture
some 12 year old boy took a picture of
like the hotel
and in one of the windows a place like
this they think this evil spirit hanging
out it's like this black
like what's weird they have a picture of
it yeah let me see what's going on
because this picture
uh ghost cecil hotel
that one is yep that's from a 12 year
old's
uh camera i cannot tell what's going on
here
yeah if you don't believe in it that
could just be a reflection or
that is kind of creepy though it could
also be a demon
paranormal activity you all believe in
it that's how
that's my boy that movie [ __ ] me up
that's my how dare you bring up that
movie we're talking about real [ __ ]
uh have you have you has my boy zach
baggins done
cecil hotel i know he i know he did the
comedy store yeah he did the comedy
store
two hours oh [ __ ]
this is december 2nd yeah so it's just
last this just happened oh he just did
it
i'm going to text him would you have
gone in there with him
yes oh you would have done it i'm super
into this stuff
alarmingly didn't you do ghosts didn't
you do that i was on his
haunted place in denver i was terrified
so it was jay ask jay about it
because he goes hey man we'd love to
have you on sometime like yeah no doubt
let me know that was like a month
before and then at 11 o'clock at night
he's like yo it's going down tonight we
need you
no problem i was embedded in my
underwear i texted jay i'm like yo
you got to come with me so i picked jay
up i we were
jay was scared jay was scared
i don't know what's going on here yeah i
was terrified
yeah it's a hotel yeah peabody uh matt
mansion
yeah i was terrified you guys all talked
about already i guess we did
yeah didn't they didn't they like try to
leave you somewhere yeah
they left me where she was murdered they
left me down there for an hour by myself
in the dark
hey dog here's a here's a uh night
camera night
all you vision like just sit here this
is
literally the spot she was murdered what
were they doing chilling like
upstairs searching for stuff supposedly
but also
probably making fun of me he loves this
one didn't you hear like no
she said my name brendan yeah
i was terrific i wonder if he's done the
spawn ranch
where manson where's that at oh ranch is
only seven miles from my house i biked
there that's why i biked and
posted the video and [ __ ] i wonder if
he's done it
spawn ranch that's there's a bunch of
these found bodies on spawn ranch
from that were linked to the charles
manson stuff oh yeah
damn how about that when i get off stage
at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figure out what
you look like i'm like what this from a
bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you got a
[ __ ] together
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic song